foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar advances
and challenges in targeting Kinesis in
cancer Therapeutics
I am at action of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by BPS bioscience
to learn more visit bpsbioscience.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Asia
shanaz Naim post-doctoral fellow Dana
Farber Institute at Harvard
hey Chef you may now begin your
presentation
thank you uh and thank you for the
invitation
so my talk today is about targeting BTK
in CLL
and I'll start with a small a brief
introduction
on chronically and positively chemia or
CLL so what is CLO
clo is the most common B lymphoid
malignancy in North America in 2022 new
CLL cases is estimated to be at twenty
thousand one sixty which represent about
1.1 of all new cancer cases in the
United States
the median age of diagnosis is 70 years
with only a small fraction of patients
younger than 45 years
CLL is a indolent or slow growing
malignancy characterized by clonal
proliferation and accumulation of mature
b cells within the blood bone marrow
lymph nodes and spleen
this is a very slow growing disease
people can usually sort of have normal
life you see a lot for a very long time
because asymptomatic before the disease
can pick up momentum and there is a need
for medical intervention so treatment is
often initiated only in the presence of
active symptomatic disease
so let's talk about risk factors and
Driver events in CLL
80 of the CLL patients exhibit one of
the four chromosomal abnormalities their
deletions on 11k 13k 17p and transom h12
so these events can be biological
predictors to patients response to
therapy another important predictor is
the itsv mutation status
so there are two subtypes of CLL and
these can be seen in the schematic on
the slide
the subtype that's unmutated with
minimal or no hyper mutation in the
antibody Gene and the subtract that's
mutated with much more somatic
hypermutation
so the ighv mutational status
discriminates between the more mature
genetically stable CLL and the more
immature genetically unstable clo so
patients with unmutated ighv have a more
aggressive disease cause than those with
mutated igsv
so we have over 200 candidate genetic
drivers identified so far with
increasing amounts of CLL being
sequenced we are learning more about the
driver events and their impact on
disease relapse and the clinical outcome
so this just shows a snapshot of the
evolution of the Seal of the treatments
over time
and as you can see the therapeutic
landscape of CLL has significantly
evolved as our understanding of this
disease has advanced
the currency or treatment includes
chemotherapy agents Inhibitors of the
BCR pathway and an inhibitor that
targets cell death pathway
now targeted therapy
um which is picked up in the last decade
is a Cornerstone of precision medicine
it's really transforming cellular
treatment by focusing on specific
molecular or drivers of the disease and
these treatments have significantly
improved the survival rates of CLL
patients
the BCR signaling pathway so the B cell
receptor a component of the pathway is
important for the proliferation
maturation and survival of normal B
cells
so how does this pathway gets activated
on antigen binding to our BCR
zd79 A and B which are non-covalently
associated with the receptor gets
phosphorylated by sick and Lin which
leads to formation of a complex that
involves BTK
now BDK tyrosine kinase is a member of
the Czech family kinases and plays an
essential role in B lymphocyte
development and function and as you will
see BDK is a critical mediator in this
pathway
so as I mentioned before after antigen
engagement sick and lean phosphorylate
cd79 A and B which phosphorylates BTK at
the
tyrosine 551 site
and then BTK gets autophosphorylate
sorry autophosphorylated retires
integer3
so now the immediate Downstream
substrate of BTK is field Sigma 2 which
then gets phosphorylated by BTK and this
triggers a Cascade of events all
signaling down from the PCR pathway
and this pathway activates transcription
factors that are significant for
decisions such as proliferation survival
apoptosis and migration of B cells
so BTK enhances the signal between the B
cell receptor and the nucleus
and in CLL
BTK is overexpressed both at transcript
and protein level compared to normal B
cells leading to an amplification of the
BCR signaling pathway
an amplification of this pathway leads
to increased Pro survival signals
through its effects on ph requirements
below Sigma 2 and NF couple B
and this leads to these survival
pathways are essential for the survival
of the CLL cells
to this led to
the development of specific Inhibitors
that Target vtk
the first group for ptk Inhibitors are
covalent inhibitors
the core covalent because they bind to
their target by forming a covalent bond
a brutally was the first of his class
the first one that came out and while
the efficacy of this drug is very good
long-term treatment can be associated
with toxicities and in some cases these
substitutes can be quite severe we also
have the Next Generation Inhibitors in
the same Clause a color brute name and
Zana brutonic
so here we can see the kinom selectivity
among the covalent Inhibitors so the
size of the red circle is proportional
to the degree of inhibition and as you
can see a brutinib has activity against
quite a few kinases which may explain
some of the toxicity is observed with
this truck
has activity against much fewer kinases
than not brutonium but a color britainab
is a more specific of the covalent
inhibitors and all three have the same
binding mechanism
as shown in the diagram below they all
bind to the c481 side on uh with found
within the ATP binding pocket in the
kinin's domain of ptk
and another problem that arrives with
this group indicators with abruption and
specifically is despite clinical success
long-term treatment can lead to acquired
resistance with the most commonly
reported one being the C4 red 1s
mutations and we also have the less
frequently identified activating
mutations in the downstream substrate of
BTK which is PLC gamma 2.
the presence of this mutation at this
site
um abrogates the covalent binding of all
of these drugs
so this led to the development of
non-covalent BTK Inhibitors these were
designed to bind to BTK without relying
on the C4 at one side thus providing
options for those patients that has
progressed with the bdkc401s mutations
so we have a few
um
in pre-clinical development and two of
these spiritual brought brought an
abandoned to Britain were currently in
clinical trials
and here you can see the kind of profile
of the two
non-covalent Inhibitors and
um as shown in the graphs aperture
Brittany is highly more selective for
BTK compared to Britain with 300 full
selectivity for B2K versus uh 370 other
kinetics
so this is a timeline of the BTK
inhibitor so far so as I mentioned
before a Brittany was the first of his
class to come out in 2014 it was FDA
approved for patients with CLL who have
received at least one prior line of
therapy
in 2016 it was approved as an initial
treatment
in 2019 acala brutonet the second
generation BDK inhibitor was approved
for treatment affected our patients with
CLL and in 2020 a combinations have been
involving a brutinib and ritoxin map
which is a
cd-19 antibody
um for the first line treatment of CLL
you can also see
um
the second generation inhibitor designer
Brittany which is currently in clinical
trials in phase three as of 2017 and is
currently on track to be FDA approved
very soon the non-covalent BTK
Inhibitors came fairly late to the
clinical trials however uh project
brutonium is likely to be approved
really soon as well
so here we are looking at some
pre-clinical data on one of the
non-covalent Inhibitors them to protonet
so this is a publication from
Dr Jennifer goyak from Ohio State
University in 2018. so what I've done
here is cells from Aboriginal patient
that acquired C4 rate mutation at
progression so these cells were treated
in vitro Vietnam to brutally and are
brutonium for an hour for one hour and
then the effect on the BCL signaling was
um was looked at by looking at the
phosphorylation of phosphor BTK and as
you can see
pre-relapse prior to getting the c4h1s
mutation both drugs effectively inhibits
um phosphorylation of BTK which is the
blood since it is in the most uh
somewhere in the middle bpdk 223 and
then at post relapse on acquiring the C4
red 1s mutation abruption abuses this
efficacy whereas an empty protein
continues to inhibit phosphor BDK
and on the right is a plot looking at
the cell killing
so here's primary serial cells well
isolate isolated from a brutally
resistant patients who all had the c4h
minus mutations and they were treated
with them to Brittany Ben and protonate
and the effect on cytotoxicity was
measured as you can see there was a
significant
um cytotoxicity compared to the control
with neptubrutinib which is also known
as archael 531
but this wasn't achieved with uh
with a brute nib
so this is some pre-clinical data from
our lab on petrol Brittany so what we're
looking at here is cells from BDK wall
patient were treated in vitro with
Puerto Roma and the effect of these
drugs on BCR signaling pathway
I said by looking at the phosphorylation
of proteins in this pathway and cell
death were assessed in vitro
so in the first blood in the western
blood you can see that both drugs quite
effectively inhibit Foster BTK at all
concentrations and in the middle one so
as the doors curve of inhibition of
phosphor BTK and both drugs inhibited
phosphor BTK with comparable ic50s and
in the right
um
you can see the cell killing compared to
the control proto-brutinib and a color
and a brutalib significantly inhibited
as significantly caused cell death
so then we also looked at the effect of
virtual protein bonus if you're red ones
in vitro model so here these are h293
cells expressing both either we take a
long type or
btkc4h1s and we treated them in vitro
with a range of
drug ranges
um sorry petro brutonib and hybridinab
using a very endocratrosis and you can
see in Wild so I bought drugs
effectively inhibited phosphobutica and
phosphoblc Gamma 2 however in the cells
expressing c4h1s perturbating continued
to inhibit phosphobidic and POC gamma 2
whereas at brutonium fails to have this
activity and this can be also seen more
clearly in the plots on the right
where uh in HEX genet3b decal wall type
both drugs inhibited phosphor B2K and
it's similar ic50s whereas in the
hexagon93 you put a Britain renovated at
16 nanomolar whereas the plutonium
failed to inhibit phosphor BTK
so these are serial patient cells with
the c4h1s mutation again treated in
vitro with virtual brutinib and the two
covalent Inhibitors abruption of
benicolor
and on the right you can see
um is density geometry plots for
phosphor BTK and there is a significant
inhibition of phosphobdk with virtual
protein as 0.6 micromolar whereas we did
not observe
um significant inhibition the
temperature or a color
so here we're looking at the cytokine
secretion in vitro in the Supreme agents
after c4h1s
um expressing our cells were
treated in vitro with Aboriginal
portability
and similar to the beta signaling
pathway
um that we saw earlier
um we saw a significant reduction in the
secretion of both of these cytokines
with virtual Britain and whereas we did
not observe that with their brutal or
color
so part of britainable has shown
promising efficacy for patients in trial
it was considered safe and active in
multiple b-cell malignancies
overall response rate in patients with
CLL was 62 percent including patients
with c4h1s mutations at 71 and without
physical wall type at 66 percent and on
the right we have another publication
that recently came out which looked at
the effect on the phosphorylation of BDK
in these patients are currently on trial
on but are brutonium so they looked at
from cycle one day one which is Baseline
up to cycle 41 which is after three
months of therapy and there was a
reduction in possible ptk in these
patients
and we also have this other publication
that came out in February which now
reports um
resistance mechanisms cheaper to
operation app
so nine so they report uh 9 out of 55
patients had disease progression while
on Purge of Britain
and genomic analysis on the peripheral
blood samples from these patients before
treatment and at the time of disease
progression revealed that seven out of
the nine patients had one or more new
mutations in BDK at the time of
progression
and as you can see on the
under a graph below on the plot below
um whereas resistant mechanisms to
covalent mutations is often
characterized by mutations at the c4h1
side these new mutations were in the
other regions of ATK and some of these
mutations also convert resistance to
some BTK covalent inhibitors
another interesting thing about these
mutations is that some of these later
kinase that protein as you can see in
the plot on the right
they fail to
um
have phosphorylation at the
bgky23 however despite this protein
being Kine instead the BCR signaling
pathway appears to be intact with
increase in Downstream signaling
molecules such as phospholicity and
phosphorus
so more work needs to be done to
elucidate the resistant mechanisms to
this class of Inhibitors to understand
this further
but this will
this will help revise the therapeutic
options for these patients who's
developed these mutations
so thank you for listening
thank you so much Asia now we will pass
the presentation over to vernac bearing
hi good morning everyone it's a pleasure
to be here from San Diego and speak
after Isla's fantastic seminar uh in my
presentation
I will touch on me briefly about on the
clinical relevance of kindnesses just to
expand a little bit from BTK then I will
introduce the audience to BPS bioscience
and I will spend about 10 minutes
describing some of our kindness related
tools such as proteins our circuits a
knockout plenty virus library and
reported systems
so for viewers who are really less
familiar with kindnesses I have
Illustrated a few Basics as you know
these enzymes are classified depending
on which amino acid the phosphorylate
tyrosine Celine Throne of both tyrosine
and serine threonine for the so-called
urokitis
the receptor kinuses are alkalized at a
plasma membrane and the non-receptive
kindness are in the cytosol
I put separately the cycling different
kindnesses that are a whole family in
themselves
um phosphorylation is the most frequent
price translational modification of
proteins and it regulates protein
function it does so but I'll train the
conformation of a protein as
localization enzymatic activity
interaction with partners and so forth
so kind of the trigger signaling
Cascades that ultimately regulate many
biological processes such as metabolism
subproliferation it's a cycle
progression survival death and
differentiation
because they are involved in so many
biological processes they're also
involved in many pathologies so in
cardiovascular and degenerative disease
for example you'll find the kinase
lrk2 involving urine Health kindnesses
that are involving ER stress
um they're involved in diseases of the
immune system because they are part of
the T Cell checkpoint regulation
um they contribute to immune suppression
for example the time kindnesses they
contribute to inflammation
um
as with csf1 added contribute to
autoimmune disease
they are very much involved in cancer so
all the cdks contribute to cell cycle
progression there are a lot of
oncogenated kindnesses
um for which the mutation amplification
or aberrant activation will directly
promote tumor formation so I indicated
here a few of these unpredicting
kindnesses like the hcf receptor kit
her2 and so forth
um
and their transcriptional regulators
so at the intersection of the immune
system in cancer you're going to find a
few kindnesses that can be involved
either in autoimmune disease or in blood
tumors
and then at the intersection of the
cardiovascular system and cancer you'll
find kindnesses that are involving
angiogenesis such as the EGF receptor
and a pdgf receptor
so here are a few
um every approved kindness Inhibitors in
oncology this is a subset of these
Inhibitors as they target
tyrosine kindnesses and only those that
are involving oncology so for example
you're not seeing here uh the Jack
Inhibitors that have been approved for
immune diseases the first housing kind
of that was ever approved was imaterim
which is also known as polybeck that was
initially used to target blood cancers
with a BCR able fusion and was later
extended to Target other able-linked
tumors such as a gastrointestinal
stromal tumor
it was followed shortly after in 20 in
2002
um by the first generation EGF receptor
inhibitor which is chiffidine and all
these early successes have opened the
door to further development a small
molecule-based targeted therapies
because of their High efficacy and
because of their large market shares
so you're seeing the number of small
molecules that have been approved
increase over time and to the right I
also added
the 2021 approval for uh chivu sameep
and try to suclid even though cdks are
not having kindnesses but I wanted to
Showcase this because they are the first
cdk inhibitor approvals
um so now not all drugs against
kindnesses need to be small molecular
Inhibitors so for we said to attack
kinosis for example that have an
extracellular domain outside of the cell
they can also be antagonized using
extracellular antibodies so what I'm
showing on this side on the right are
three NDA Improvement of hormone
antibodies against the EGF receptor
and then I also indicated the three
generations of small molecular
Inhibitors with a light blue being the
first generation in a dark blue being
the third generation
um and this is to keep in mind that once
a drug against one kindness as in the
clinic and is showing efficacy there
will be additional drugs that will be
designed just because as we learn more
about the side effects of the drug or we
learn more about mechanism of resistance
we need better drugs with better
Affinity or drugs that can recognize a
mutual that pops up during resistance
for example
so if you're working on kindnesses what
are the tools available to accelerate
your research projects so to study
kindness is in the trope
you may want to look at the structure of
some of the protein dominance for
example the kindness domain you may want
to analyze finding Partners such as
drugs antibodies you may want to design
a novel assay and very often scientists
will use purified proteins either in
white Type 4 or in the mutant form they
may want to type these proteins in
addition they will want to measure the
kindness activity
now to study a kinase in a cellular
context you can overexpress
this kindness in a particular set type
of interest
um
a Target validation study may also use
crispr-mediated knockout or may compare
the white type of nutrient forms the
biological function and especially the
activation of relevant selecting
Pathways can be conducted using cell
lines or using reporter systems
so now let me introduce my company BPS
bioscience where a scientist founded
scientist-driven company our mission is
to advance new scientific discoveries
that lead to therapies by creating
innovative solutions for research the
company was established in 2005 by on
resume doctor on Rizzo PhD uh we're
innovating drug discovery
in various spaces such as immunotherapy
epigenetics source code V2 and South
signaling we are industry leader in
recombinant proteins and hard to purify
complexes we also a leading producer of
recombinant cell lines and cell service
assays were dedicated to delivering
novel as a kids self-systems and virus
virus-based tools for research
our core Technologies are summarized
here
we can provide custom proteins and
conjugates
we specialize in high Purity High Health
high yield expression of recombinant
proteins formulation activity testing
labeling can be customized to research
needs
cell line development we provide stable
cell lines that Express validated
surface proteins and reporters their
lives to probe cell pathways
our expertise with crispr cas9 also
enables the manipulation of protein
expression in cells given by nokene or
by no count
virus engineering we provide high
temperature lead viruses
vsvs and aavs adenoviruses Adeno
Associated viruses sorry that can be
used for viral infectivity assays stable
cell engineeration crispr no carrot and
much more
will surprise screening and providing
services
um we save you time by evaluating lead
compounds with our biochemical and cell
based screening services and coming soon
are our ipsc derived cells
um so we'll we'll provide differentiated
cardiomyocytes and neural cells derived
from induced pluripotent stem cells
so for proteins
um they are used to study the structure
the effect of the mutation
The Binding of an antibody to design
assays
for receptor targeting candidates most
of the time you will want only the
kindness domain of course we cannot
purify uh the full protein because it
would like to pass my membrane so it
wouldn't be followed correctly but will
produce either the tracerial domain or
the kinase domain
and again expression can be done in
bacteria insect mammalian cells
available in white Alpha mutant forms
multiple tags are available the Affinity
purified formulation can be customized
and we always will test the activity as
part of the quality control
Chinese Advocates will allow the measure
of the activity of the kindness drug
kinetics and EC 50s they're very simple
as is really you are the kindness and
your drug pre-incubate them and those
are trait in ATP and then I add the kind
of scroll uh and measure the signals so
their I'd say kids are non-radioactive
they're provided with a detailed
protocol the kindness to trade the ATP
and the buffer are all included they
accurate robust and specific and I put
to the right are two graphs that were
open with two highly related kindnesses
work one and row two uh studying an
inhibitor and measuring the ec50 on this
inhibit
we also have theories of fluorescence
polarization acid kit so these acid kits
have been specifically designed to
um probe the gh2 pseudokinase domain of
uh the Jack Familia proteins so the drug
family of kinases that include Jack one
two three and tick two play very
important roles in blood cancer and in
immune diseases
gh1 is the kinase domain and gh2 is the
pseudokinase domain and at the bottom
you see an illustration of the linear
structure of the protein with the
different domains and then you see a
little illustration of
um a purpose conformation and how these
domains interact with each other and
what shows is that she is one domain and
the gh2 domain
are very closely
um interact with each other very closely
the pseudokinas domain have very weak
kindness activity and so you can't truly
measure its activity using a kindness
essay cheers two domains however play a
role in the function of the kindness and
both the gh1 and the th2 domain are
required for signaling
so the GS2 domain does buy an ATP
which accounts for the pathogenicity
that is associated with mutations in the
gh2 domain and there are many mutations
in these domain that have been found in
leukemia
um
and by your sponsor leukemia so the ATP
binding pocket of GS2 is accessible to
small molecules and it is therefore a
very attractive therapeutic Target
especially because it is expected that
individuals against gh2 may be someone
less toxic than existing Inhibitors
against gh1 gh1 domains
so the fluorization the fluorescence
polarization as it gets uh bypass the
need for a kind as they say so there is
no kind of activity for the gh2 domain
they consist of a purified GS2 domain
for example project 2 or tick two you
have a small probe that is labeled with
the fluorophore so when the probe is
free it has low fuel resistance
polarization
upon interaction with gh2 it forms a
much larger complex and the fluorescence
polarization is now high so the
formation of the complex is to a higher
signal of your recent polarization in
the presence of a of the inhibitor
the small molecule blocks access of the
probe so the probe remains free and put
our fluorescence polarization remains
slow
so this is indicated here this is
uh on the right dividing of the gh2
probe one to the Jack 2
um gh2 domain and as you can see as you
increase the amount of GS2 you also
increase the signal because more and
more the probe is going to be associated
with GS2 now if you were to add an
inhibitor you would be able to measure
um the decreasing signal that is induced
by the inhibitor and you would be able
to measure the ac50 for your inhibitor
so let me tell you a little bit
um about knocking out the kindness so
this is to help with the validation
studies we have generated a knockout
kindness Library which is based on
crispr casting technology this is a
library of antiviruses they're off the
shelf viral particles
and they're all in one system which
means that the viral particle the
lentivirus will transduced the cas9
a single guide rnas that are needed for
The Knockout and they also contain a
pure missing piromycin selection Gene so
you can use them with any cell of
Interest including non-divided cells
regardless of whether you sell
um contain cost cut nine so you don't
need to use a cas9 expressing cells to
use this antivirus library now every
vial of the library
um
targets one gene
but every vial also contains five
different single guide rnas and this is
to make sure that we get the best
knockout that is possible so each file
contains
five SG rnas and targets one gene
and then the full Library
um
which one is individually constructed
sequence verified and purified
the full Library covers 690 human
kindnesses and pseudokinases uh five LG
rnas each and also contains a 150
control energy rnas
and they can be used in a biosity level
2.
so the applications are grown they go
from viability screening you may want to
identify kindnesses that are involved in
survival
you may want to do a synthetic lethality
screening drug resistance study and so
forth it is possible to identify which
kind is activated transcription Factor
um by using a reporter cell line
for transducing the library for example
um
so that brings me to our report systems
these are used to test the activation or
the inhibition of a particular cellular
pathway using a high purpose printing we
have over 20 available cell lines 70
available reporting systems
it is based on the activation of a
particular transcription factor of
Interest this transcription Factor TF
will bind to the response element and
this will induce the the transcription
of the reporter that can be either
luciferase or can be uh fluorescent
protein like egfp once the reporter
protein is expressed you can measure the
expression either through uh
immunofluorescent studies or through
measure of luciferous activity and
reminiscent success
so in a case of egfp or RFP which is a
red protein you can do fluocytometry
microscopy
[Music]
and with luciferase which is a
luminescent system you can read the
signal using aluminometer this is a very
robust quantitative and reproducible
measure of single activation and can be
very useful to see if your kindness is
active and which cellular Pathways
they're working with
so we have a few promoter specific
reported cells that are off the Shelf
ready to go to measure the activation of
transcription factors such as AP1 cred
CSS and so forth and they exist in
various cell types we can also make
the report itself that you're interested
in uh if you don't find it on our
catalog so on the right you see for
example the measure of
um
activation by Agonist tnf Alpha on top
and then at the bottom graph is a
measure of the inhibition of any
capability by a specific inhibitor
if you would prefer to make your own
reporter cells you could use lengthy
viruses these uh will allow for the
robust quantitative and reproducible
measurement of transcription Factor
activity again we have over 70 reporter
systems available and they are useful to
study transcription Factor activity and
I might point out here that it could be
for short-term studies you can do a
transient transfection and measure the
activity of your transcription Factory
in response to any signal or with an
inhibitor but it can also be used to
generate a stable cell line uh using the
antibiotic selection that we have in the
antiviruses
um determination of ic50 or ec50 is
possible and you can screen Inhibitors
uh in cell cell based assets which is
very important to look at a cell
relevant uh response
finally our CR services will help
scientists evaluate lead compounds with
biochemical and cell based screenings we
have a unique panel of over 500 assays
our 3 000 square foot facility is fully
equipped with state-of-the-art
instrumentation and we also have bilayer
interferometry for protein interactions
with all screening and profiling
Services we provide a comprehensive
report that contains raw data and
analyze data all the graphs and detailed
protocols and since we produce our
proteins our enzymes and sellers
in-house for this essay you can
customers can trust that our quality and
consistency are of the highest level
and we are your partner in drug
discovery
thank you
we will take any questions now
thank you a chef and Vernick for your
informative presentations we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
okay let's get started our first
question is
several tyrosine kindnesses are
implicated in BCR signaling pathway
diagram and introduction indicated Lin
and sick tyrosine kinasses Upstream of
BTK
are there Inhibitors being developed
against these kindnesses as well
and do you know if such Inhibitors show
any kind of efficacy at least in
pre-clinical data
clinical data lean and sick Inhibitors
have shown
um efficacy as to whether any of these
are in clinical trials at the moment I
have to
um double check that but having said
that some of the couple of the
non-covalent Inhibitors that I showed in
my presentation today uh named Britain
have also inhibits sick so that kids
sick and BTK and another one cg806 which
is in pre-clinical development also is a
dual bgcasic inhibitor so yes targeting
all the molecules that you mentioned is
definitely beneficial to getting a
larger inhibition on this sectoring
pathway
great thank you for your response
question two
is mutation of 16 481 the only genetic
modification scene in abruptanib
resistant patients
are there other mutations seen in BTK
and if yes have you tried fertile breed
andib on some of these other mutants
so the C4 rate one side appears to be
the predominant one another then so
cysteine there are other substitutions
that happen at this site and it has been
shown in pre-clinical data and in clinic
that pledge opportunity representative
against those there are however a very
small percentage of patients that shown
a couple of other sides and now that we
have seen resistant mechanisms on
non-covalent
inhibitor vertebral German trial we now
know that petroborating is also
resistant to those mutations so there
are some mutations that are common to
both
okay thank you
it looks like we have time for one more
question
and this question is for you vernik
you showed that BPS has a knockout
kindness lenovirus Library
can I order a single lentavirus if I'm
interested in only one kinase
Oh Yes actually absolutely I skipped
over this maybe a little fast uh so the
library is made of single files uh it's
possible to order any single kindness
that you want to Target we also offer
panels which means that you can if
you're studying say the Jack highness
family or proteins and you want all four
of them you may just order these four
um so we have either individual
kindnesses panels of custom panels and
the library
okay thank you
okay it looks like that's all the
questions we have for today uh thank you
a chef and Bernie do you guys have any
final questions or comments for your
audience
okay
I would I would like to say thank you to
Aisha that was a very interesting
presentation I'm really really happy
that you were here to present to us
today so thank you very much thank you
for the opportunity I'm glad and as a
final comment I think I would like to
say that um BTK Inhibitors
um it is increasing proven efficacy in
CLL is become a Mainstay in CLR
treatment so
great all righty well thank you again
Aisha and also to vernik for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor EPS bioscience for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcasts can be viewed on demand
lab Roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
bye